then where do you see filmmaking 10 to
20 years from now that's that's a good
one that's I think it's all about
immersion the viewer into each of the
stories more and more that's why we're
seeing gravity and films like that
and that's why people tried the 3d but
3d was a fad so I mean it's 3d it's not
gonna exist anymore but the goal is
still I think for for movies to immerse
people into the story whether it is on a
blog bursar format like gravity
literally putting this viewer in a movie
and even I think for some Indies I mean
it's all about immersion in terms of
creating places and atmospheres and
moods that the the viewer is gonna get
immersed into and and so I think both of
studio filmmaking an indie filmmaking
are looking for the same kind of thing I
hope which is immersion and that's why
there are so many great ways of getting
there which I think are not even created
yet I mean all the stuff that James
Cameron is is preparing for his next
avatar movies in LA I mean it's like II
you can either love it or hate it
I understand that some people don't
believe in that or hate these kind of
filmmaking but you have to recognize
that this guy for example is a total
pioneer and it's making things progress
and for the sake of a star each time and
so I get I think that immersion has
always been since the dawn of
moviemaking the the the model for for
from movie makers and I think that
immersion will still be the goal and how
can we go to more immersion would that
be this new screening systems that the
Fox is is trying right now which is
three screens at the same time it's a
brand new screening system which is
gonna arrive a thing soon in some
theaters in the US which is a which is
truth which is three screens - one on
each side and one in front which is kind
of a Dolby Surround applied to to film
which is which is I know it sound kind
of weird but I mean let's right let's
see how it goes so there is this kind of
cinema there is the the all digital
capture cinema where you have this
camera which you are pointing everywhere
into a digital world so basically the
cameraman is pointing into the world and
you're seeing where you are shooting and
you have so many great forms which are
developing so I think the future is
gonna be bright grand new forms some
some fads like like the 3d which are
gonna be talked about for a year and
then nobody's gonna talk about it
anymore
but some of these techniques are gonna
stay and I think that's that's great
because even us right now as indie
filmmakers we can find great ways to get
the audience even more into the story
and the movie business
10 to 20 years from now one thing which
would be which is SATA is I think right
now there is a I mean of course I'm the
first one to say that was what George
Lucas and Steven Spielberg were saying
about there is a gap which is
accentuating between blog browsers and
and indie films and that's true that
indie film films are getting even more
indie and even more recluse
to people and and blockbusters are also
getting even more focused on only
superhero movies so you got like it's
kind of sad to see these two poles
getting apart in a way but because I'm
an optimistic person I think there are a
lot of ways to bring the two together
again like if you're looking at
Christopher Nolan I was telling you is
the most brilliant indie filmmaker and
bland and studio filmmaker and he's
doing this the two at the same time I
mean movies like Inception of the Dark
Knight were done in a very indie way I
mean with these DP a willing feature
they come from this world and they know
how to this shoot in a very independent
way even though they're making the the
the biggest budget of their time and so
that's why I think there are people like
that who can do this both at the same
time
you